well it'll be crazy
thank you we want to take the
opportunity tonight thanks to the
Academy to speak about something really
important to us as you can imagine we
worked really hard spend a lot of spend
a lot of time and we think that we had a
lot of luck make by making this
impossible but for us there is something
much more important than work and luck
and much more precious and rare and it's
goodwill the goodwill from all the
people close to us the people who help
us without demanding anything in return
the kindness in people eyes and people
without which for wait for us as not to
be only about filmmaking it's what makes
people trust in themselves be themselves
and for us it's the proof that you can
go ahead and do something good
so it's why with my team we want to
thank the Academy first of all for all
the week and for this huge award we want
to thank all the teachers from the
school we want to thank the school all
the persons who believed in us and in an
outsider school we would like to thank
most wiser from you if iam Mahela was
the composer and the voice of the bird
and we would like to just thanks
individually some guys so I would like
to thank even a my love and all the all
my team my crew my parents no mercy and
my two little brothers luego any NGO
will be here in next year of my
girlfriend and Lisa my grandparents my
cuisine and all my friends from Andre
from Al from London from Paris
hi I would like to thank my parents for
first of all my dad and a big house to
my mom who is not here anymore
in this world but to whom I owe
everything and I would like to thank my
brother-in-law and pull in all my family
who supported me for for a long time and
some of them are here tonight and I'm
really grateful wanting my love and my
Owen mode my best friends and all of my
friends who supported me since the
beginning Sidonie and my amazing crew
here yes thanks
so I would like to thank my my family my
parents my brother and my sister
I would like to thank Elsa with a person
really important to me I love her
and thank you consume every now and
davida the person I respect the most
and thanks to my classmates thanks to
all the people who supported me and who
believed in me from the for the game and
this means a lot to me
hi I would like I'm sorry for my French
I would like to thank my parents for
their support my own my love which is
here tonight and of course my team
because it was amazing to reason thank
you so high I'm gonna make this quick to
rub this up but I really want to take my
family and friends of course especially
my mom who is here tonight I would like
to thank my thanks my best friend Nita
even though she's all over the world
you're always here for me so I know
you're here with me tonight I would also
like to thank all of the people had that
helped me especially Elise Clothilde and
especially the bass a new cabin when
Alex you know you're here and I love you
guys thanks everyone